[Musique]
elle me disait toujours que nous autres
les sudistes ont hérité nos bonnes
manières des british et je me disais
c'est quand même dommage nous en ayez
pas garder un peu pour vous
[Musique]
jamais dit frappé avant d'entrer en fait
on avait une invitation les spa resort
blague mais qui est venu sous la forme
d'une bouteille on est de la boutique du
tailleur kingman à londres vous ne
connaissez peut-être aux kids mode oui
c'est pour ça vous avez des beaux
costumes et de letat la mode sont doutés
est exact c'est ça va être super chic
pour voir si j'ai bien compris vous
voulez me faire croire que c'est normal
pour un tailleur de pirater un système
biométrique de sécurité avec une simple
titre à la con
[Musique]
désolé messieurs ça va pas le faire
aller gentiment vous met à genoux et
m'expliquer pour qu'il vous bossez
vraiment
[Musique]